[Musique]
mamadou ciré ly n'a plus d'espoir son
rêve canadien s'éloigne tu peut financer
beaucoup d'argent pour les procédures et
voilà on te refuse carrément et sans
raison valable c'est décourageant
vraiment après quatre refus de permis
d'études en deux ans sa formation dans
une école canadienne est compromise et
avec elle son avenir en pâtisserie site
arrêté dit elle a été très bon dans un
pays pour chercher du boulot face à rafa
c'est pourquoi elle n'a fait pas par la
fée musée reste ici mais c'est dire et
pas pour moi je n'avance pas mamadou a
obtenu une bourse d'études de plus de
15000 euros de la province du québec
mais comme lui ils sont environ 70 %
d'étudiants africains francophones à se
voir refuser un visa par le gouvernement
canadien contre 35% pour les étudiants
non africains aussi ont été dé ce parce
que tout peut arriver n'importe où mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a sacrément s'ils ne
veulent réellement pas
mais clint des avait raison
face à ces refus massif un comité
fédéral s'est penché sur la question
après un mois d'auditions son rapport
est sans appel
décision arbitraire difficultés à venir
étudier au pays immigration canada ne
facilite pas l'arrivée des étudiants
africains francophones
des shops et les agents ne devrait pas
avoir de préjugés quand il commence à
étudier les candidatures des étudiants
la demande peut être évoluer en tant que
tel nous avons également aux commandes
et qu'il y ait un médiateur au sein du
ministère de l'immigration chargée
d'examiner les taux de refus
pour remédier à ces taux de refus
élevées 34 autres recommandations ont
été faites par le comité permanent de la
citoyenneté et de l'immigration
au québec bonjour mamadou vous vous
allez bien
[Musique]
l'avocate de mamadou reste pessimiste
les statistiques de l'année 2000 21 sont
accablantes sur plus de soixante dix
sept mille demandes d'étudiants de pays
africains francophones environ cinquante
trois mille ont été refusées par
immigration canada vous pourriez perdre
temps et argent en misant sur un tel
projet d'étude je vous recommanderais de
fait davantage pour un programme qui
vous permet de rentrer comme
travailleurs étrangers temporaires à
travers un emploi mais vaut refus
précédent vont toujours vous nuire donc
il va falloir réellement travaillé le
plan de retour dans quelques demandes
que vous allez répondre et je fais ta
mère deschamps
l'opération séduction du canada
fonctionne les demandes de permis
d'études venant de partout dans le monde
ont presque triplé en sept ans selon
immigration canada avec pour la plupart
des étudiants l'espoir d'un visa
permanent à la clé beaucoup en les
pressant de ceux de s'être fait flouer
par justement de cette publicité
canadienne là où est-ce qu'on leur banc
un rêve qui a tué pratique n'existe pas
un rêve un certain pour les étudiants
africains obligé de présenter un plan de
retour au pays particulièrement
détaillées pour un étudiant africain
c'est réellement le parcours du
combattant parce qu'il doit démontrer
davantage que quiconque
que son plan est véridique alors on
prend pour acquis que c'est un bus
détourné qui sont de mauvaise foi et qui
veulent rester au canada alors que c'est
le code de bien des gens des gens en
provenance d'europe en provenance d'asie
qui ont qui nourrissent tous le même
rêve de venir au canada
également dans le viseur du comité le
logiciel chimiques il permet un
traitement plus rapide des demandes de
visas mais résume en quelques lignes des
candidatures d'une centaine de pages on
a toujours les mêmes refus je ne suis
pas convaincu que vous quitterez le
canada à la fin de votre période de
séjour contenu des perspectives
d'emplois limitées dans votre pays de
résidence contenu de votre situation
actuelle en matière d'emploi contenu de
vos biens mobiliers et de votre
situation financière ce qui nous
préoccupe c'est l'opacité du système et
le fait qu'on n'ait pas réellement
d'information sur la façon dont la
décision est prise et qu'on regarde les
motifs de refus qui n'ont aucun lien
avec la preuve qui a été soumise c'est
certain que c'est très très questionnant
pour l'association le québec c'est nous
aussi le rapport fédéral tombe à pic il
vient appuyer leur projet de loi pour la
création d'un défenseur des droits en
immigration le gouvernement pour la
prochaine rentrée a rendez vous avec
l'histoire il a été mis au pied du mur
et force est de constater qu'il ya un
problème désormais le gouvernement à des
recommandations pour y mettre fin ou
pour diminuer les impacts de certaines
lois l'immigration sur les personnes
venaient d'afrique des étudiants
africains qui pourraient être victimes
de préjugés raciaux selon le rapport
fédéral contacté par france24 le
ministère de l'immigration reconnaît des
failles dans son administration
mais estime que des progrès ont déjà été
accomplis la stratégie de lutte contre
le racisme lancé par le gouvernement
trudeau en 2019 n'aurait cependant pas
réussi à endiguer un racisme systémique
qui pénalise les étudiants africains
il ya des façons de procéder des façons
de faire qui s'offre ont parfois au
détriment de certains c'est ça qui fait
que ce système est aisé secret qu'on
doit s'attaquer aux mécanismes il faut
aborder comprendre il faut les
décortiquer il faut les analyser l'état
demandent une révision en profondeur
le ministère de l'immigration examine
toujours les 35 recommandations du
comité fédéral une réponse du
gouvernement est attendu dans les six
prochains mois